ก็
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนดีค่ะ
ฉันสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้า
คะวันนี้เราพบกันที่ช่องไหนคะ
ช่องคอมเพลนเซเบอร์ไทยค่ะ
เป็นวันวันนี้ที่เราอัดวีดีโอเป็นวันวัน
อะไรนะคะอังคารค่ะ
เดือนที่ 7 เนาะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนกรกฎาคม
ค่ะเดือนกรกฎาคมปีพตตปีธานีเนาะเดี๋ยวพี่
เอ๋
อยู่ไหนกูเอ๋เอาปากกาขอโทษที่หายกลับมา
แล้ว
กลับมาแล้วอ่ะจะ
มีประกาศเอาสีอะไรจริงสีเมจิ
อาปีใช่ไหมคะฟรีไทยเรากันนะคะปีพตต
เบผชเท่าไหร่
2564 ค่ะ
ปีพต
2564 นะคะ
ร้าวปีคศ
[เพลง]
เท่าไหร่คะ
2021 ค่ะมีคศ 2000
2021 นะคะ
2021 ปีพศ
2564 นิติไทยนี้เป็นปีสากลนะคะ
มินิ
คลิปนี้คลิปตัวเล็กเป็นระดับไหนคะครูฟ้า
นี้เป็นระดับดีกินน่อฮา
แนะนำ
คิดว่านักเรียนที่ฟังครูเอ๋กับครูฟ้าทุก
คนแข็งแรงดีเนาะ
คิดใหม่อีกคิดแข็งแรงเป็นครูวิทย์ใช่ไหม
วะ
แรง
วันนี้แรงไหมอันนี้แข็งแรงเอายังโอเคอยู่
ค่ะ A มากไม่ปวดหัวใช่ไหมคะโอ๊ยปวดหัวปวด
หัว
ไม้ปวดหัวค่ะไม่ปวดหัวดีมากนะ
ไม่เหนื่อยนิดหน่อย
นั่นแหละน้ำค่ะกูฟ้าดื่มนะมีฝาหมุนแล้วก็
เปิดก่อนนะก็ดื่มน้ำมากๆ
มีน้ำดื่มน้ำมากๆนะฮะโอเคค่ะวันนี้ครูเอ๋
มีของจะมาให้กูฟ้ากับนักเรียนดูนะดูว่า
เป็นอะไรมี 4 อย่างนะคะเสียทีหากเฮ้ยหา
เจอแล้วดี
ลูกค้าอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
อันนี้เรียกว่ากรรไกรค่ะกรรไกร
งั้นไกลเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะ
กรรไกรเอาไว้ตัด
อะไรตัดตัดผม
ได้ตัดผมก็ได้ตัดกระดาษไหมคะครูเอ๋มี
กระดาษ
สมุดครูเองไม่เป็นไรอ่ะ
ก็มีกระดาษ
กระดาษนะคะตัดอะไรได้อีกคะ
ตัดผ้าเหรอคะง่ายพากูเอมมิผ้าเอกกันกาย
อากาศตัดให้คำหาป่า
แต่กูห้ามบอกครูเอกตัดผมนะ
ผม
ไม่ได้กลับเดี๋ยวต้องกว่า
งั้นน่ะมีกรรไกรที่บ้านครูฟ้ามีกรรไกรไหม
คะ
ที่บ้านครูฟ้ามีกรรไกรค่ะแต่ที่ห้องไม่มี
เนาะแต่ที่บ้านมีกรรไกรนะคะอ่านที่บ้าน
ครูเอ๋มีกันไรมากๆหลาดีอันครูเอกกูเยอะมา
อ้ายสิแล้วก็เขาปิดแล้วประมาณนี้กันไกล
ประมาณสิบอันหาประมาณสิบแล้วก็ครูเอ๋ก็
เจ็บแล้วก็ให้เขาเหอะ
เพราะว่าครูเอ๋นี่
แต่งงานจะไปหา
อันนี้คู่เอ๋
แต่งงาน
สามีน่ะเดี๋ยวใช้กรรไกรตัดกระดาษตัดผม
แล้วก็วางแล้วก็ลืม
มึงไปซื้อกันไก่แล้วก็ตัดแล้วก็ลืมซื้อ
ซื้อ
[เพลง]
กันก็
คุยกันเก็บทำไมกันใจมากๆๆๆ
พร้อมนะมีเด็กกันไก่มากๆตอนนี้ก่อนเก็บ
มันก็มี 1 แต่ตอนนี้มี 4
วิจันไก่ตัดค่าตัดผมฉันก็กรรไกรตัดเวลาทำ
อาหาร
[เพลง]
โอ้ยอะไรอัดหมูตัดไก่มั้ยเฮ้ย
ค่ะก็ได้หนูก็ได้ๆ
[เพลง]
เราก็มีกรรไกรมีต้นไม้
ต้นมาเม้นท์
มีอาจมีต้น
เดี๋ยว
นี้มีต้นไม้แล้วต้นไม้มีกิ่งไม้นะฮะมี
กิ่งไม้ต้นไม้เล็กๆนะคะเล็กๆหน้าที่
กรรไกรตัดค่ะบางทีตัดกับประวัติดึงไม่
โอเคก็ใช้กรรไกรตัดนะคะคู่
และก็มีกันต้นไม้นะคะอ่ะนะคะมีกันใจแล้ว
ผู้เอกชอบ
ผมนะปะตักได้นิคมนะคะ
ต่อไปค่ะครูมีอะไรอีก
ใครไก่ไอ้ไก่
ไก่
[เพลง]
1 ฟอง
1 ฟอง 1 ฟองแล้วก็ครูเองมีใครๆ 1 ลูก 1
ฟองบางทีพูด 1 ลูกบางทีพูด 1 ฟองโอเคนะคะ
มีใครไกลสุดฟ้าชอบกินไข่ไก่ใน
ไฟล์ชอบกินไข่ไก่มากค่ะน้าไก่ไข่ตีเยาว์
แล้วเดี๋ยวตุ้มหูอร่อย
มีอะที่ร้านมีกระทะ
เมย์มีกระทะนะคะกระทะแล้วก็มีไฟ
เปิดไฟนะคะเราก็
น้ำมันเนาะ
ใส่น้ำมันนะคะน้ำมันใส่ลงไปแล้วก็ออกไข่
ใช่มั้ยตอกไข่แล้วก็เอาไข่น่ะ
ตอกใครตอกไข่ใช่ไหมคะไข่ก็จะอยู่ที่นี่
ชุด
ไข่เจียวใช่มั้ยไข่ดาวเดียวค่ะเดี๋ยวไอ้
ดาวไข่ดาวก็ชอบไข่ดาวก็ชอบ
ค่ะ
เพียวใครเจอจะเป็นแบบนี้เนาะอ่าตัวเมีย
อันนี้แหละรสไข่ที่นี่ก่อนไข่ไข่แล้วก็มี
ซ่อมแล้วก็ตี 4 ตีๆราคาแล้วก็ใส่น้ำมัน
เอาไข่ใส่ไข่เจียว
ปูปลาชอบกินไข่เสียวหอบมากค่ะหลัง
[เพลง]
กินง่ายดีนะคะเดี๋ยวเนี่ยอร่อยนะคะ
ตอนนี้ครูเอ๋เรนเจอร์ตาเลี่ยน 3 เดือน
กินค่ะ
อ๋ออ๋อกินไข่ได้เป็นแบบไทยจะเรียนกินไข่
ได้แต่ว่าถ้าเป็นแบบไทยใช้ไทยเองไข่ไม่
ได้
กูฟ้าก็ชอบกินไข่เนาะไม่ใคร 1 ฟองมาท้า
มีขาย 2 คนก็ชอบกินอ่ะไข่นะคะ
โอเคไข่
6 บาทแล้วนะหนึ่งฟ้อง
6 บาท 6 บาทอันนี้เป็นใครออกกันอีก
เดี๋ยวผมหวานที่แท้
แพงไหมอ่ะไอ้ 1 ฟองถ้าจะดูเป็นสิทธิ์ฟ้อง
6 บาทนั้น
มันจะเป็นสิบชั่วโมง
เองคุณไข่ๆวาดรูปไข่อย่างเดียว
อาจใครเนี่ย 1 ฟอง Smart  1 ฟองเนี่ยตก
บาทหนาน
อันนี้ไม่ไม่มี brandname แต่ว่ามาจาก
ฟาร์มนะฟาร์มเป็นของเธอเด็กมาโอเคนะ
ถ้าเป็นในซุปเปอร์ 1 ลูก 10 บาทค่ะถ้า
เป็นออแกนิกโอ้โห้โหแพงมากแพงมากแต่ว่า
size อันนี้เอาคลินิกไซส์เล็กนะฮะเล็กๆ
ถ้าเป็น
ไข่ธรรมดารู้สึก 5 บาทไม่แน่ใจกูเองไม่
ได้สักปิ้งอันนั้นๆมากมีมีคนเดลิเวอรี่
ไข่มาจากปาล์มนะคะ 6 บาทวันนี้นะนี้ 6
บาทแต่ก่อนไม่ใช่ 6 บาทเนาะนะคะๆใส่ทีนี้
ต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าภู A มีอีกเรามีอะไรคะมี
ผ้าไหม
ไม่ไม่สวยไม่ได้รีบ
[เพลง]
หน้าไหมเป็ดสีอะไรอ่ะสีฟ้าฟ้าไหมเป็นสีสี
ฟ้า
สีฟ้า
มีสีเขียวรวมกับ
ป้าเขียว
ไม่เป็นก็เป็นสีฟ้าสีเขียวแล้วก็เอามารวม
กันนะกันเป็นสีนี้พี่ไก่ฟ้าหรือเขียว 5
เขียว
นี่ฟังน้ำทะเลค่ะ
เป็นเป็นเป็นฝาของทะเลบางคนเล็กสีเขียว
บางคนแรกสีฟ้าไม่รบกวนเลือกสี
เองบอกสีฟ้าบางคนบอกสีเขียว
Swatch เป็นฟ้าน้ำทะเลมันเหมือนทะเลฮ่าๆ
ๆเป็นภาพหมายอ่าเอาไว้
พันคอช่วยฮะ
เวลานะพี่สาว
แต่ตอนนี้ประเทศไทยไม่หนาวเป็นแฟชั่นเฉยๆ
ถ้าเวลาไปเชียงใหม่หนาวก็พันคอหนาๆหรือ
หรือเอาไว้
ไปออฟฟิศหนาวก็พันคอได้เนาะวันนี้อยู่
บ้านมะนาวเอาไว้
อะไรคะขอเวลาไปข้างนอกร้อนหรือฝนตกก็โอเค
ฝันเอาไว้แบบเออดีนะเนี้ยเพราะว่าเป้า
หมายเวลาเวลาร้อนก็ปิดที่นี่ได้นะฮะร้อน
แล้วร้อนมากรังสี UV นะคะ you  a  c  e  r
r หลิวฝนตกฝนตกนิดหน่อยนะป้าก๋อง
กันฝนได้นะกันฝนได้นิดหน่อยนะคะที่หนาวอา
กอพันคอได้เป็นผ้าไหมให้เหมือนภาพปกติ
อื่นใช่มั้ยไม่เหมือนไม่มีเหมือนภาพท่า
ใหม่จะมามาจาก
นักกันนะคะน่ารักจ่า
นะมาจากตัวไหมตัวใหม่ก็จะเป็นเป็นเหมือน
หนอนอ่ะเนาะอ่า
น้องเล็กหนอนไหมถ้าหนอนมันเป็นอย่างนี้
ใช่ไหมคะ
หนอนอ่าแต่ตัวนี้หนอนใหม่
หนอนเนี่ย 1 วันจะเป็นจะบินได้
มีนายเป็นเป็นผีเสื้อ
ผีเสื้อเห็นไหมเนี่ย
ขนาดหนอนมาเป็นผีเสื้อก็จะหนอนไหมเนี่ย
บินไม่ได้นะฮะบินไม่ได้เป็นผีเสื้อที่บิน
ไม่ได้ก็เอาไหมจะนอนไหมมาทำข้าวไหมนะฮะๆ
แพงนะยังไม่เป็นไรแค่นี้ซื้อแพงๆแต่อัน
นี้ฟรีโอเคฟรียังไงวัยผู้ใหญ่ได้ฟรีมีคน
ให้
คนให้มากมา
นานแล้วเวลาอายุนิดหน่อยมีคนให้ตอนนี้
อายุ 53 ไม่มีคนขี้
นักแล้วซื้อซื้อราคา
นิดมีผ้าไหมน้อ
r.o. เคหะคันคอย
น้ำน้ำ
4 แปลงแปลงลบกระดานอ๋อมันมีว่าเข้าอ่า
มันเป็นฝุ่นนะคะ
จะคุยเลยใช้อันนี้ค่ะใช้เมจิกกับวันนี้ลบ
ไม่ได้
ลบไม่ได้แต่
กระดาษอันนี้ต้องขิง
ต่อไปค่ะกูปากอูเอมีงานน่ะเงิน
เงินทัศน์ uvo เงินฟรังก์สวิสเงินดอลลาร์
เงินอะไรฮะห่วยเงินไทยเป็นงานเหรียญ
เหรียญในเห็น 1 ตัด 1 บาท
1 บาทบ่าแล้วก็มีเหรียญ 1 คู๋มีเหรียญ 1
บาท 2 เหรียญ
ก็เป็นกี่บาทล่ะคะครูป่า 2 บาทค่ะ 2 บาท
หน้าแล้วมีพระเอกก็มีอันนี้ด้วยคือฟ้า
อะไรคะเหรียญ
ให้ๆเห็นไหม
ฮะไม่ห้าสิบปางไหมคะ 50  Star
เพลงบาป
1 บาท
1 บาทเท่ากับ 100 บาทต่าง
100สตางค์งั้นเนี่ยครึ่งนึงก็เท่ากับ
50 สตางค์ฮ่าๆครูเอกก็มีเงิน
มีงาน
1 บาท
ห้าสิบสองบาทห้าสิบสตางค์
ดีกว่าถ้าสิบล้างซื้ออะไรได้บ้างครูเอ๋
เอ๋ซูชิได้ไหมอยากกินซูชิ
ปี 2021 ไม่ได้
ๆอ้ะนะ
ค่ะ
แต่ว่าเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อน
[เพลง]
สตางค์ซื้อไข่ได้หนึ่งฟ้องน
โอ้
โห้นะไม่ต่อก่อนคิดว่า
20 ปีที่แล้ว
2 บาท 50 สตางค์ซื้อไข่ได้หนึ่งฟองนะคะ 1
ฟองมหาๆอ้ะฟ้าเดี๋ยวเรามาทวนอีกครั้งนะคะ
ว่าเรามีอะไรกันบ้างอย่างมากเลยที่เรามี
มีอะไรคะ
กรรไกรค่ะกันกันอะไรอย่างที่สองเรามีอะไร
คะอย่างที่สองเรามีไข่ค่ะขายมั้ยไอ้นะคะ
อย่างที่ 3 เรามีอะไรคะ
ถ้าใหม่
ทำไหมนะคะแล้วก็อย่างที่ 4 เรามีอะไรคะ
เรียนบาท 2 เหรียญหน่าแล้วมีเงินใช่ไหมคะ
เงินเหรียญข้อสองเรียนครูเอ๋มีเงินทั้ง
หมดเท่าไหร่คะ
2 บาท 50 สตางค์ค่ะ 2 บาท 50 สตางค์
ครูเอ๋มีครูฟ้ามั้ยมีใช่ไหมคะเมื่อ
อ้าที่มีไม่มีไม่เป็นไรนะคะไม่เป็นไร
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าจะมี
ยังไงหาดิกูเอกจะให้ครูฟ้า Exercise
Exercise นิดหน่อยแล้วก็กูกาก็จะมีอ่ะมี
มีเงินถ้า
มี
มีไข่มี
กรรไกรเราก็มีเงิน 2 บาท 50 สตางค์เหมือน
ครูเอ๋นะแม่วันนี้น่าจะให้กูป๊าจะ
ถ้าใครชนะอันนี้กรรไกรใช่ไหมคะกันใส่ฝาก็
อัลเบิร์ตขึ้นมากำไว้เวลาครูพูดกันไกลก็
2 นิ้วอ่ะนี้
อ่ะ
กรรไกร
ตายเหมือนกันกันไกลๆกันไปนะคะอะกูเอง
ไข่ดิบ
ตกแต่
ตัวเองมีไข่ใช่ไหมคะไข่ไข่กลมกลมรูฟ้าไม่
มีไข่ครูบาก็กำมือ
กำมือใช่ไหมคะคืออันนี้ก็เป็นไข่ 1 ฟอง
ลิตรไข่ 1 ลูกไข่หนึ่งใบโอเคนะ 1 ฟอง 1
ลูก 1 ใบผู้ได้นะคะจริงพูดต่อตั้งแต่วัน
เนี้ยฉันคำว่าไปนะคะไปนี้ค่ะหนูฟ้อง 1  2
1  2
ฟองนะคะอะนะกูเอกก็มีนี่ถ้าไหม
ทำมั้ย 1 ผืนนะคะอะอากุงฟ้าไม่มีผ้าไหม
ใช่ไหมครูบาก็ไม่มีเออแบบ
นั้นเนี่ยการอาบน้ำปูปลาอ่ะกรรไกร
อันไกล
ไข่
ถ้าหมาย
ข้าวไหม
ความหมายก็แบมือครูเอ๋มีงานใช่ไหมคะมีงาน
ไทยมีงานเท่าไหร่นะ 2 บาท 50 สตางค์ค่ะ
เมื่อกี้ทำไมฉันยังไงนะเว้ย 2 บาทติด
สตางค์ค่ะใช่ทายไม่ถูกพระมีเงินแล้ว
สิบมานี่ไง
50 สตางค์ให้หน้างั้นเนี่ยเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋
จะพูดภาษาไทยนะเดี๋ยวเช็คถูฟ้าวัดได้หาก
มือกับสมองแล้วก็หูนะคะหนูเน็ตหนู
ไม่เอาหูหนาหูอะบ้าภูฟ้าหูหูฟังอ่าฟังครู
เอกพูดนะคะแล้วก็คิดนะ
กูพูดอ่ะกรรไกร qu-pac ชั่นกรรไกร
ไข่ผ้า
หมายเอาไหม
ไข่หนึ่งฟอง
เวลาพูดไข่ 1 ฟองซื้อไข่ 1 ฟองโอเคนะคะ
ไข่ 1 ฟอง
สองบาทห้าสิบ
โอเคนะ
ให้ดูแล้วนะครูฟ้าฟังแล้วก็แอ็กชันนะคะ
ได้ค่ะคู๋ฟังที่ 1  through  a  x สั้น
ด้วยนะคะ
กรรไกร
ไข่ผ้าไหมไข่
1 ใบ 1 ฟองสองบาทห้าสิบ
อ่อนนักเรียนเดี๋ยวนักเรียน x ช่างกับครู
ฟ้าเนาะพูดครูจะพูดช้าๆก่อนนะคะได้ค่ะได้
ค่ะ
หากตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้นนะกรรไกร
ไข่ผ้ามีค่าไหม
ไข่ 1 ฟอง
สองบาทห้าสิบ
โอเคถ้าช้าๆอีกหนึ่งใครนะคะ
กรรไกร
ไข่ผ้า
ไหมไข่ 1 ฟอง
สองบาทห้าสิบ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
กรรไกร
ไข่ผ้าไหม
ไข่ 1 ฟอง
สองบาทห้าสิบ
[เพลง]
Step ที่
กูพูดไหมดีขึ้น
ได้หากแกนไกลไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟองสองบาทห้า
สิบ
[เพลง]
เร็ว
กรรไกร
ไข่ผ้าไหม
ไข่ 1 ฟอง
สองบาทห้าสิบ
โอเคคู่เอกจะเร็วขึ้นนะเร็วขึ้นอีกนะได้
ค่ะ
กรรไกรไข่ข้าวข้าวไหมไข่ 1 ฟองสองบาทห้า
สิบ
โอเคกูฟ้าได้ละเดี๋ยวก็กูฟ้ากับคู๋แข่ง
กันเก็บไว้ได้ค่ะใครเป็นคนพูด
ให้เขาพูดก่อนนะอ้าคู่ความพูดก็ได้ช้าก็
เร็วเร็วๆแล้วก็เร็วสุดโอเคมั้ยอ๋อ
ฮะโอเค
เป็นไกลไข่
ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟอง 2 บาท 50  50
2 บาท 1 ปองไข่ผ้าไหมไข่เป็นไกล
กูฮะ
Reverse เลยค่ะเอามันต้องแอดไวน์ขึ้นใช่
ไหมเรียน
เท้าพูดอะไร
ไม่งั้นตกใจอะไรหรออะครูเองไม่คุยหรอกนะ
อ้าอร่อยๆคนละกันอันไก่
ไข่ข้าวไหม
ไข่หนึ่งฟ้อง
2 บาท 50 บาทโอเคนะคะเร็วเช่นนะคะแล้วมี
แต่ไม่เหล็กนั่นจะเร็วขึ้นเรื่อยๆนะคะ
Action ด้วยกันนะคะนักเรียนกันใด
ไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟองสองบาทห้าสิบโอเคนะ
เร็วๆนะเร็วๆนะ
ครับพร้อมยังพร้อมแล้วค่ะพร้อมแล้วบอก
เพลงฟ้อนอันนี้เร็วๆนะคะกันใจ
อ่ะ
กรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟอง 2 บาทค่ะ
รู้เอง
ขอโทษ
กันไก่ไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟอง 2 บาท 50
ตัวเองไม่ได้อ่ะอยู่
ใกล้ไอ้ชั่นด้วยไม่ได้เข้าฟังและได้อ่า
ให้ความพูดเหรอพูดเร็วๆนะแต่ยังไม่ต้อง
กลับนะคะลองพูดแล้วอย่าง
หนึ่งสองซ่ำกรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟองสอง
บาทห้าสิบ
รู้เอง
นักเรียน
ยังไง
ฟองสองบาทห้าสิบ
อยู่ไหนสายนวด
คะเด็กๆใช้จะเล่นนะคะกรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1
ฟองสองบาทห้าสิบใช่ไหมคะอ่าหน้า 1 ฟองสอง
บาทห้าสิบเป็น 1 ซอง 2  50 อันนี้จะยาก
แล้วถ้าเร็วๆเราก็จะเป็นกรรไกรเสื้อผ้า
ไหมไข่ 1 ฟองสองบาทห้าสิบแบบนี้ก็ได้ไม่
ต้องเก็บนิ้วก็สองไปเลยแล้วก็ 50 เนาะอ่ะ
โอเคเดี๋ยวแบบ rivet แบบแบบโตเก่า
มีกรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟองสองบาทห้าสิบ
เวลากลับนี่เป็นยังไงคะ
50 ใช่ไหมสองบาทห้าสิบ
สองบาท 1 ฟอง
ฟองก็ลงไหมไข่
1 ฟองไข่ผ้าไหม
ไข่กรรไกร
โอเคงั้นเอาไม่ต้องเร็วๆก็ได้แล้ว
นะเนี้ยเดี๋ยวเราไปเราก็กลับด้วยกันนะคะ
โอเคค่ะครูปากพูดก็ได้ค่ะโอเคค่ะอ่ะ 1  2
กินข้าวเกมไกลไข่ถ้าหมายไข่ 1 ฟอง 2 บาท
50  50
2 บาท 1 ฟองไข่ผ้าไหมไข่กรรไกร
เขตวันนี้น้านักเรียนก็รู้จักนะคะไปไข่
เราก็ผ้าไหมแล้วก็รู้จักเกมที่เด็กๆไทย
เล่นขยับมือจะมากรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ฟอง
สองบาทห้าสิบนะคะแบบนี้นะคะนักเรียนลอง
เล่นดูนะคะวันนี้ครูเอกกับครูฟ้าต้องไป
ก่อนแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะตอนไปอย่าลืมกด
like กด Share กด Subscribe ที่ด้วยนะคะ
เออ
หน้าค่ะสวัสดีค่ะวันนี้อาอา